at what point did you know you wanted to
start a company um
so my sophomore year of college I was at
Penn and I actually started my first
business at the end of sophomore year so
I went to Stanford for a three-day boot
camp called basis entrepreneurial boot
camp or something like that and I
remember going to the Jamba Juice at
Stanford and they asked me can I see
your Stanford ID and I said I don't have
one why and they said oh you'd get like
10 or 15% off your Jamba Juice and I
paid full because I was a Penn student
but I remember thinking wow that's
really cool that's a great perk for
students I should do this at Penn so I
get back to campus and I walk around to
all the restaurants and I say do you
have any loyalty program for students
and they also know and so I said okay if
I got your logo in the wallet of
thousands of students at Penn would you
give them ten fifteen percent off and
every single restaurant and bar said yes
and so I said okay and I'm not gonna you
know pay you for that or anything and
I'm actually gonna charge students and
they were like okay we don't care and so
I ended up over sophomore summer and I
also was doing an internship at
Blackstone in Tokyo but meanwhile okay I
was started as we all do yeah I'm but
meanwhile I actually I went about hiring
this like company in China to create
thousands of cards that would put the
logos of all these businesses on the
back and I called it the Penn eats card
and I sold I got back to campus at my
junior summer I hired all my friends to
basically go around selling these cards
for 15 bucks a pop and we sold like
thousands and it was awesome and it was
very very very cool and that kind of
gave you the bug I was addicted I
thought the concept of creating
something from nothing and solving a
problem or you know helping people is
just such a cool opportunity and why
wouldn't you want to do that over and
over mmm because you weren't you weren't
an engineer right you're right no I took
a bunch of computer science classes but
I was not what I would call an engineer
yeah and so were you inherently drawn to
creating a software startup or did you
like try out other ideas and that first
it was like a Wix website and a bunch of
plastic cards not really much software
the software there though I did
to be fair sell a bunch of cards online
but not much software there I remember
though my senior year when I wanted to
start that next project and that's the
one I worked on with my co-founder now
of way up JJ we very much were keen on
having it be a software bazaar you know
an Internet company ok but you didn't
start it immediately after school so the
story was way up the high level is my
senior year I'm happy to tell like the
funny version of it from college mice
that the high level is my senior year JJ
and I worked on a project together that
would help college students find campus
ambassador jobs and so we worked on that
we've launched it and then I went and
went to Google in California and then I
moved to India to lead brand initiatives
for Google JJ went traveling around the
world as a backpacking freelancing web
developer and the horse all good
backpackers do went to McKinsey in New
York and so we kept in touch over the
years but that website kept growing and
growing to tens of thousands of users
and big businesses and so on and we knew
we each wanted to start a company and so
we quit our jobs two years after college
and started way up with the insight that
that website we had started in college
which was really just a project had
grown so much you know at YC they say
make something people want if you build
a website that you barely do any
marketing work for and it's grown that
much then we knew that they had
something and so we shut down that
website because it was just like a kind
of half-ass project but we took the
insights from that and built lay up off
of that okay so I'm really curious about
how and when you decided to leave Google
because a lot of people who could start
companies and are in the position you
know like financially they have enough
flexibility to leave just kind of get in
this cycle like oh you know they get a
raise every six months or whatever and
they stay there forever yeah oh man
Google is a cushy job it's an awesome
job grace yeah hard but really awesome
okay so I always wanted to start a
company full-time after college but my
senior year I applied for so I had
already done a summer internship between
junior and senior year
Google as a product marketing manager
intern I got the offer I also got the
offer at a top-tier visa a venture
capital fund and for me I had got enough
advice that and I'd started that penny
its company saw that there was so much I
had to learn whether it was managing
people legal documents like marketing
sales and so for me I basically said I
want one experience that will help me
before I start y-you know before I start
whatever company I one day started I did
not know it was gonna be kept or that it
would be web and I said I really want to
do it for two years whatever this job is
I'm gonna learn as much as possible for
two years and then I'm gonna quit and
I'm gonna start a company and hopefully
do it with a founder a cofounder that I
love which I have done and I got these
two offers and I didn't know which one
to take which one would set me up for
more success to start I said to HR in
both of them I want you to know I'm
gonna leave this job in two years I'd
start a company is that okay Google so
cool I mean they especially the program
I was applying for and that I got the
offer to is called the APM M program
associate product marketing manager job
okay and the whole program is filled
with alumni they hired like 25 to 50 us
college students each year to be in this
program and it's filled with alumni who
have started unbelievable businesses
Kevin Systrom started Instagram britmore
and started Brit + Co and the list goes
on at some some former Googlers - I'm
Robby Stein was a sorry some former
Googler they're all former Googler
actually someone from my high school -
Robbie Stein has started a really cool
companies called stamps sold out to
Yahoo so long story short all of these
people were in this program so they
actually said it's totally fine if you
leave after two years and start a
company
meanwhile the VC fund was actually like
yeah we highly recommend that you do VC
for two years and then get your MBA or
start a company and this VC fund had had
many many successful founders as well
one who just recently had his company go
public so I I couldn't shoes and so I
did what I always tell college students
they should do which is cold emails
someone who they want the advice from so
Roelof Botha was someone who I had seen
speak
the Stanford bases entrepreneurial boot
camp it's all going kind of full circle
so at the end of the day I email Roelof
Botha and I say you are you know one of
the best venture capitalist in the world
you've seen he's up Sequoia and I said
you've seen so many successful founders
grow huge businesses I want to be one of
those founders I want the best possible
experience I can get beforehand which
one would you suggest I do go to X Y Z
fund or start my own or go to Google in
this program and he said I would get the
best possible operating experience I
could get and Google is one of the best
operating companies in the world tech
companies especially he'll be surrounded
by great managers great engineers you'll
meet great talent that you might hire
one day so go Google good I've heard you
talk about this on a couple of other
podcast I love cold email yeah me too
actually I am one of the people I really
admired in San Francisco when I was
still living in New York I emailed cold
emailed him Skyped him and I was like oh
man it's just so weird I'm gonna be in
San Francisco like next week are you
gonna be around he's like yeah I'll be
around and then I just bought a flight
the best if you could afford to do that
that's the best entrepreneurs do that a
lot apparently to get like venture
capital meetings I thought that was
funny it totally works so say you're you
don't have a brand name or whatever
you're just a college student just like
you exactly can you like walk us through
the steps that you use to cold email hmm
totally so to start I have rapportive on
my computer which is this software that
LinkedIn bought but basically if you
install it into chrome and your Gmail
what you can do is you can figure out
someone's email if you can't find it
already online by basically guessing so
like for example I don't remember what
Roelofs email is but I probably would
have looked up sequoias domain so let's
just say it's sequoias comp my guess is
Charlotte Sequoia that her partner
whatever but let's just say it's the
quake calm so I'd look up the domain of
the website and then I'd guess like
roll-off be as so clay calm arbol both
that Sequoia and I'd keep guessing until
his image shows up on the right in
rapportive and that's when you know you
got the right person so sometimes if
they're big enough name you can find
their email address online but if
they're not then that's the best way to
do it so once you have that I would say
subject line has
to be something that's gonna catch their
attention so want to pick your brain
from a college student not gonna stand
out any college student can do that my
best email old email I ever sent was to
probably arguably the most famous woman
in business in the country maybe woman
in tech business in the country I'm not
gonna say your name and you can guess
and my subject line I saw that she had
taught like aerobics or done aerobics in
high school or college or something and
I had taught water aerobics the summer
between high school in college cuz they
pay a lot of money oh alright so who
knew okay so I actually like wrote in my
email and I think part of the subject
line like fellow former water aerobics
like something silly but it caught your
attention because if you see something
ridiculous that someone clearly had to
do a lot of research to find out about
they're gonna open the email and then in
the email I wrote you know dear blank
and I start off with I'm a college
student at blank you know so and from in
my case I'm a pen senior currently
trying to figure out what I want to do
with my life between two job offers so
it just gets to the point of you know
being short sweet and here's Who I am no
one doesn't want to help college
students I feel like the second you
graduate you lose this huge badge of
pride that you get to say I'm a college
student and the second you graduate like
people are much less likely to help you
so use it and abuse it while you're in
college yeah but I mean I get cold
emails all the time I hope I don't get a
barrage of them after this but I do get
a lot so and they only start with like
I'm a college student at X school yeah
and then get to the point what do you
want to help with and ideally show that
you've done your research so why are you
asking me so you know in a specific case
for a rolloff
I remember I said something to the tune
of like you've seen so many successful
founders if I had just asked him where
should I move New York or San Francisco
like why would I a squirrel off both of
that right so I do think that a very big
part of your email should be saying why
are you asking this person what do you
want from them who are you and then show
somewhere in there that you've done your
research and that you're not just trying
to email like famous people mhm um I
think if you do those things you'll
probably get a good response rate we did
a podcast with Casey and I said about a
month ago and
he literally has picked your brain as a
Gmail filter to trash so I would not
recommend picking someone's brain I
would not recommend asking them out for
coffee or 20 minutes for a phone call
people answer short questions exactly
and sometimes I get people asking me
about hop on a phone call and I know it
sounds so crazy but like literally my
calendar starts at 8 a.m. and stops at 1
a.m. almost every day 5 to 6 days a week
and so for me 20 minutes on calendar is
actually a really big deal asking me an
email that I can just answer on my walk
from you know one meeting to another is
not and so and to diverge a little bit
you talked about your calendar I read
online that you don't sleep a lot is
that true still yeah okay so how how
much you sleep okay why don't I start by
just saying this is a genetic thing most
people in my dad's side of the family
don't sleep a lot and so it's not like
I'm wearing this with a you know with
pride and trying to show off I just
don't need sleep so if I have any sip of
alcohol I do sleep so if I have like a
glass of wine I will fall fast asleep or
a beer or anything but assuming I don't
drink which is most nights I can go 3 or
4 hours of sleep and I'm good to go and
I'll be just as energetic as right now I
think right now I'm going off of like
three three and a half hours of sleep
same with my co-founder but he's
shouldn't be like that because he
doesn't have that gene he's just crazy
and so your whole life you've been like
this yeah I mean in high school I
remember my friend Laura came to me one
day and was like I have a Hanukkah gift
for you and I said what she was like I'm
gonna be your assistant because I feel
like you never sleep and you have such a
crazy agenda I'm gonna calendar and I
just want to help you I was just like I
don't need an assistant but thank you I
think I've always had like a crazy
calendar that's wild so given that crazy
schedule do you have any like particular
health regimens you need to like stay
normal people are gonna judge me but I
don't work out I think I've been to the
gym once in the last year twice in the
last three years maybe um maybe a little
more than that I don't really work out I
love walking around New York so I guess
that's exercise I'm I don't like taking
the subway I love walking or Juber if I
want to call and I need quiet but I eat
pretty healthy I'm not like a
I don't like sweets much so yeah you're
not uncopyable tomorrow's people who do
yoga every day and by the way I don't
judge people do guys a lot of my friends
do yoga I'm just not like a I don't know
I hope I live a long life my family most
people live a long life and most people
are about as regimented walking is very
good for you yeah yeah I drink a lot of
water oh if you sit down with me at a
meal you will hate me because I will ask
for two pitchers of water because I will
drink water the entire time when I'm not
talking we should have more sorry all
right so more of the tip stuff so what
are the most common questions you get
when you are getting these cold emails
from college students and what tips do
they ask for for internships I probably
the most common one which is an awesome
problem to have as which internship
should I choose which job should I
choose I get that a lot
I wonder if it's because yeah like the
real life story um I get a lot of people
asking for advice when they're a student
entrepreneur and they're starting a
company and I think that's amazing I
mean when I started my business in
college I would say I was one of like
five people I knew who had starting
companies and now I feel like it's a
prerequisite just graduating from
college in the u.s. or at least at Pat
it just seems like everyone's starting
businesses which is funny because it's
not like I graduated so long ago I
graduated in 2012 but it definitely was
not as common back then so I think
that's another one I get a lot ok and so
what what kind of answers do you give is
it very specific or do you have like a
mental model for choosing this kind of
thing it's very specific and often I
respond saying like you need to give me
more context here oh yeah because I
appreciate if you want to keep the email
short but if you're someone yesterday
email me I think this student had seen
my TED talk about like 8 things you have
to do before you graduate or whatever
and so he emailed me and he said I loved
your TED talk I'm choosing between these
two job opportunities which one should I
take and I was just like I don't know
anything about you I don't know what
your goals are I don't know anything
about these jobs I don't really have
time to look up each job can you give me
more context so then he did so I think
it's nice that he tried to keep it short
and sweet but I could only do so much
okay what do I know - you know yeah one
opinion yeah what about on the actual
application side because I saw you guys
have tons of content on your site for
students yeah what what are your tips on
just preparing yourself to apply for an
internship assuming it's very
competitive but you have you know like
probably the right qualifications for it
and we really do it's web.com slash
guide or way of jack-up slash blog we
have a ton of content like thousands of
verticals I what I will say is number
one and this is not meant to be
self-serving but we have these profiles
on way up that are in my opinion a much
more holistic perspective on who you are
versus a LinkedIn profile that's just
your work experience or a resume that
people read the bolded words and then
ignore the rest our profiles I'm way up
focus on your github if you're an
engineer your youtube if you are
performer or a public speaker your
Instagram if you're a designer they show
you're a volunteer your hobbies your fun
facts and so it's a little bit more of a
holistic perspective of who you are and
we hear from our recruiters that if a
perk reader looks at your web profile
your LinkedIn profile if you even have
one and your resume
they're like significantly more likely
to message you and be interested in your
application if they see your way a
profile okay so first of all I know this
sounds self-serving but I honestly would
say create a way of profile and promote
it um other than that I think a lot of
people don't apply for that many jobs
because sub Career Service offices tell
you'll only apply for two or three jobs
that's wrong don't do that I for a lot
more than that the market unemployment
rate thank goodness is so down and you
know and therefore people are really
getting hired left and right especially
if you're technical you know especially
if you're a lot of things and so I would
say applying for a bunch of jobs and
then really the the feedback the advice
I'd give most often for people going
into an interview is an acronym I like
to call reef re AF okay so it's research
show enthusiasm ask questions follow-up
so research if you show up to an
interview and you show that you know
more about the company than the person
interviewing you you will impress them
period and the story you will impress
them
I remember for my google internship
interview I read in
book about Google in like two days and I
came and I was named dropping the person
who not that I knew them but like I was
mentioning you know the person who made
the Google logo and this and that and I
was showing I knew so much and I just
lived and breathed the company and my
interviewer was super impressed which
brings Lee to e show enthusiasm so as
much enthusiasm as you might think I
have right now in this interview you are
probably engaged with me because I'm
showing I actually care about the
conversation if you don't and you're
playing like hard to get or
too-cool-for-school then no one's gonna
find you interesting or engaging asking
questions and you want to ask good
questions when candidates ask me at the
end of an interview why did you start Y
up I literally roll my high I don't
literally I in my head I roll my eyes I
don't actually be rude but it's like if
you if you just googled that question
you could find it in every podcast or
interview I've done and not to say in
any way that I am saying you should know
everything about me but show that you're
coming with questions that you can't
find on Google with one Google search so
come with thoughtful questions things
like if I were to stand out in this role
as a rock star what would that look like
what are the people who really excel at
your company have in common and cetera
and then F follow-up just send a
thank-you note no one especially college
students tend to do this these days and
it makes you stick out so much it shows
this level of professionalism which
really is pretty easy to accomplish by
just sending a thank-you note
do you mean written like to like print
it out thank-you note like real or it's
interesting ribbon will help you stand
out way more however and you'll almost
get a guarantee that the person's gonna
see it because everyone opens their yeah
you know or handwritten letter
however you do want the email or the
note to get to them before ideally
before they submit their feedback and
snail mail is snail mail so maybe if you
write one and you give it to the doorman
on your way out that could be
interesting if you actually write it
after and by the way the thing you know
it should not just be thank you for your
time it should be like I really enjoyed
that we talked about XY and Z or I
really like the insight that you gave me
about ABC so as specific as it can be
that's great but I would say you want
them to ideally get it if possible
within 24 hours because then maybe
they'll get it before they submit
feedback about you and that might help
them if there
in between a yes and no I mean one way
so what about what about the
communication skills because that seems
like this whole broad category where
even if you apply your whole model like
this reef model if you come on too hot
it's like whoa okay this is intense or
if you just like it can't communicate
quite well enough through your way out
profile or LinkedIn or whatever yeah
would you advise someone to do their are
there like books that you tell them to
read or like yeah how do they handle
that I don't have any books off the top
of my head I'm sure there are some great
ones I I think the most common you know
advice we give is just practice with
your friends specifically the friends or
family members who will be honest with
you so not the ones who are yes men or
yes women but the ones who are going to
tell you when you suck and the ones who
are going to tell you when you're being
super clear and you should ideally be
practicing with someone who you think is
a good communicator because getting bad
advice from a bad communicator is not
going to help you get any better mm-hmm
okay yeah cuz I've I've done a handful
of interviews in the past on the
interviewer side and that to me can be a
little oppressive it's like I know
everything about you I've looked at
every single one of your tweets in your
whole life like drought like do you guys
encounter that kind of thing here yes I
have had some crazy ones like crazy
crazy ones but sometimes it's
appropriate as long as they're not being
stalker crazy so for example someone who
is applying to be my assistant who
actually ended up hiring and he's
amazing and his name's Brandon and you
probably met him at some point and
Brandon watched or listened to a couple
podcasts of mine before coming into
interview with me research
he showed tons of enthusiasm by the way
and asked great questions ended to a
road and I fell up but he came and so
funny he had this great conversation it
did not feel in any way like he was
creepily stalking me I didn't even know
about all the podcasts he just seemed
like you really knew his [ __ ] and he
seemed like you really wanted the job
for the right reasons it was a very
casual but but really pleasant
conversation like the one we're having
right now and that's the best interview
is one where it feels like a
conversation on an interview but at the
very end he goes I just want you to know
I think the fact that
you wear mismatching socks at all times
is hilarious and I know it's weird I saw
that but you mentioned it in the podcast
with you and Blanc yeah and I really
think it's hilarious and in honor of
that I'm wearing miss matching socks
tonight he shows me and I just laughed
so hard and I was like that is memorable
that is memorable I thought it's funny
and it wasn't creepy he didn't have my
picture on his socks that would be like
oh my god BAM this guy from our but it
was funny that's pretty good yeah I
think I would just draw the line like
anything approaching like someone's
family or their like boyfriend or
girlfriend
yeah we're good I keep fart out
what about like just this whole process
of presenting yourself to find a
co-founder how did you go about finding
JJ so basically this is embarrassing
talk about Viggo weird up okay so I in
sophomore year a little bit of a back
story sophomore year I had no idea what
I wanted to do with my life
but like most you know college standard
freshman year I came into Penn thinking
I want to be a politician because I had
interned for Hillary's first
presidential campaign in high school
senior year of high school realized at
my in college that I had interned for
one politician and really didn't like
the person and realized that a lot of
the other politicians I was meeting in
that process we're pretty scum pretty
scummy people and I just said you know
what maybe I'll go the Bloomberg route
of trying to get into politics one day
once I have like made an impact on
business but I want to do something
where I can be impactful and not
surrounded by scumbags so that not
fortunately not all politicians are like
that but a lot our so freshman year I'm
trying to figure out what I want to
study sophomore year I start studying
actuarial math computer science and
politics trying to figure out again and
then I get this email saying
anheuser-busch is interested in hiring
you to be a campus ambassador and I said
what does anheuser-busch and what's the
campus master so I google both and has
her best cool I like beer not ther beer
as much as I would like like I love blue
moon but that's fine I really you know I
like beer and then campus ambassador it
seemed like it was this marketing job
and I didn't know what marketing was I'd
never taken a marketing class I thought
marketing was making TV commercials and
that's it and so and you know obviously
much more than that so my my first
instinct is I want to get as much as
experience as possible and I want to
build my resume and hey I also get paid
that's nice and so I took the job and it
turned out that I was being hired to not
promote their beer but to help them
recruit mechanical engineering students
to work for anheuser-busch and I thought
that was a the first time I realized I
loved marketing and be the first time I
realized that the whole career services
slash college recruiting process is kind
of broken so now fast forward my senior
year I knew I wanted to start a project
because I got in the offer to Google
early and I ended up taking it by like
October or November so I kind of had the
rest of senior year to do whatever I
wanted and I thought why not start a
project not even a business but as much
as a project so I signed up for a
hackathon thinking I'm going to create a
website that will help college students
find campus and master jobs called the
campus rep so I sign up for a hackathon
and it turns out it's the same night as
I don't know some like date party or
something okay and I had to choose
between the two and what I ended up
doing was I found my way stuck my way
into I think NYC they would call it they
have to your way into the database of
every single person who signed up where
I could see their resume and all of
their information and you were not
supposed to see any mention but it's
fine I did it wasn't illegal I don't
think and so I went through every line
and looked up every single person who
signed up for the hackathon and there
was one that was by far and away the
most impressive to me and it was this
guy named Joel sleek oh man Joel JJJ
nicknames legal man and I thought I've
never heard of this guy look him up we
have like no mutual friends and why was
the impressive a bunch of reasons he
knew how to code he knew bit and I know
that sounds obvious but a lot of people
who sign up for hackathon stone he knew
how to code he had done some really
interesting projects that he mentioned
about like scraping this and this and
whatever he also had a very strong
business sense he was in the Huntsman
program which is a dual degree program
between warden and basically linguistic
studies in the college for what he was
studying so he was like huntsman program
which is really impressive program plus
he knew how to code and he'd worked on
really cool projects his hobbies were
really funny and
I just thought this guy sounds great I'm
gonna email him and if he doesn't
respond cold email him if he doesn't
respond cold email someone else I'll go
down my list but he was my first choice
the only one I emailed I called email
him and I told a little bit of a white
lie which I regret but I did say my
friends I thought to your point about
creepy stalkers I thought it'd be weird
if I said I found my way into the
database of the hackathon a message
again so I said my friends told me that
you're like really talented engineer I'd
love to meet with you for a beer at City
Tap House which is a great bar on campus
and apparently because he likes that bar
he agreed to meet with me but he totally
knew that I was lying about the friends
because in his email back to me he goes
it's so interesting that your quote
friends told you because it is how'd he
was like I know we don't have mutual
friends who told you this so that was
kind of funny and then we met and I
pitched him on the idea and he thought
campus master jobs were so interesting
and so he said let's do this and then
that obviously turned into something
more and more than just campus
ambassador jobs - that's how we met
interesting okay
and so were you where you're curious
about vetting him before you got going
because like as someone who hadn't been
you know in engineering school like what
you do yeah well I had taken more coding
classes than he had actually I'm crazy
interestingly enough but no I was like
it's just a pride I've got paying the
guy I wasn't paying the guy like we were
equal co-founders in this thing exactly
if it fails David whatever it's like
we're both going dad so I let's let's
try together yeah I didn't even think
about that I had a lot of trust in him
hmm
I still do yeah I mean obviously our
co-founder right so now you you guys are
three and a half years in you said just
under three and a half I'd say three
months three years in a few months
okay so pretty close yeah all right
what's it like now having you know
you've been at YC for a couple years
you're obviously here in New York how
are things going
so we did YC six months into the
business or five months Center so less
than three years ago ah that's crazy it
feels sometimes like a month ago and
sometimes like 10 years Oh interesting
yeah
so it's going great I mean it's hard
smarting business everyone always says
starting a business is so hard it's this
roller coaster of emotion and it's
really easy to hear that and nod your
head and say I get it but it's so much
harder to go through it but it is the
most fun I've ever had in my life and
I've learned more in the past three
years than in the entire I'm
twenty-seven so in the 24 years before
it maybe with the exception of the first
five years of my life where I learned
the whole English language but that's
that's real earnings every cuz we've
done a bunch of podcast of people have
been in YC and we've done a handful of
who people have left YC obviously but
you're not that far out right so what
have you learned in the interim like
intervening years you know I said to Sam
Altman right after YC I was at like a
lunch or dinner and and he was there and
we were sitting next to each other and I
turned him and I said you know the thing
that I've had to learn about the most
since YC that you guys did not prepare
us for at all and he had a really good
reason for why but that you did not
prepare us for at all was how to manage
people and hire a team and grow a team
that is the hardest thing ever it's
funny and ironic because our business is
a recruiting business it is so hard I
mean so hard I went on Sunday or
Saturday and did a whole talk to a group
of like 30 entrepreneurs who are all
five employees or less all about how we
came up with our way up culture values
and this and that and they all raised
their hand with questions with each
their own like the most challenging
questions about employees having you
know affairs with others Lynn this and
this and I'm just like oh my god all of
this is really difficult that's probably
the thing I've learned about the most
so like scaling an organization managing
people infinitely more senior and
experienced than you hiring those people
and convincing them to take pay cuts to
come work for you and so on so I'd say
that's probably the biggest learning we
should break that down into like
specific examples so you know say you're
you're like you're recruiting your first
like big senior person what was that
like okay and the first senior
quote-unquote person he wasn't c-level
he was like VP level
I worked with a recruiter and it was
really interesting working with a
recruiter because recruiters the first
time you work with a recruiter they
teach you so much about how you should
actually hire they teach you about
something called scorecards where and
I'm talking not an internal recruiter
I'm talking an external recruiter who
does this for a living executive
recruiters or what they call themselves
so they teach you about a thing called a
scorecard where you create a set of a
criteria for any role of things that
they have to be able to have weather
skills or culture or you know soft
skills hard skills and you come up with
this entire scorecard and then you have
to rank each person on that they teach
you about the interview process they
help you learn how to sell the candidate
I mean especially if the person has kids
and a family which this person did
coming to a company that at that time
we'd only raise nine million dollars
which is a lot of money but I was like a
lot but that's not enough to ensure that
you are going to be you know around for
years and years to come I technically no
amount of money is so you still have to
convince them of that you know that it's
worth it for them to risk their
everything to come to you so um it was
just a lot of learnings how do you sell
it I mean obviously you know you're
excited about your company and you kind
of like sell the vision you sell the
dream but like what are the the real
tangible things I think the biggest one
is definitely the person who is going to
be managing them and in my case it's me
I guess it I have to be selling that I'm
going to be a good person that they want
to work with and then I'm not gonna
micromanage them that I'm not going to
you know annoy them and then I'm gonna
be a really good partner obviously the
second thing because someone once told
me actually a bunch of people have said
this to me people quit their manager
before they quit their company and I've
seen that so very often be true here too
um and so I would say first things first
making sure that you know you convince
them that you're gonna be a great
partner for them because no matter what
the company does or what the cultures
like no one wants to work for an [ __ ]
the second thing I would say is
definitely convincing them that the
business has legs and that the business
is a great idea that can change the
world or whatever your goal is for us
it's very much to help people and that
we've already had some kind of learning
from the first at that point we'd been
around for a year that we've already had
some kind of
learning that will help ensure that we
have a real shot at becoming a huge
business and the list goes on and so
what about this is something that I had
difficulty with like managing people
whose personality type doesn't really
jell with mine I find you know if you
say they're like five to ten different
kinds of personality types and maybe
your personality aligned just like two
or three of them and then there's the
rest how have you figured out how to
manage all those kinds of people do you
do you delegate to like other people who
gel with them or what if I'm being
honest if you're working for me there's
a few things that you have to have in
personality type that I won't hire you
to work for me directly and it's fine to
work for someone else but I'm not gonna
hire you to work not for me if you don't
for example if if you don't consider
yourself kind of a little bit type-a
where you we have one of our web
principals as great as it good enough if
you always strive to just be better than
great to be the best that's very much a
good thing so I was raised by my parents
where if I was in second place why
didn't you get first and if you got
first place well that's expected if you
got a 99 my dad would call and say why
you don't think you got a 100 and I know
that sounds crazy but I work best with
people who are like that from a
standpoint of management not every one
of my companies like that and that's
good you want that diversity of thought
not just diversity of gender and race
and all that's it but also have thought
but from a management perspective I do
like having that hyper competitive and
kind of type-a personality um but there
are other things so one person who
reports to me is definitely not nearly
as I would say organized as others and
while that could frustrate some people I
know that that kind of somewhat lack of
organization is totally made up for by
that person's utter creativity I mean
they're so creative and always coming up
with really cool ideas so you just have
to balance and you have to know like I'm
going to manage this person to make sure
that you know I'm telling them please
follow up with written action items for
each of us so that you don't forget what
your action items are but I understand
that the you know that you're probably
not going to have as formal and agenda
and our calendar invite as other people
well and you just kind of live with it
and as JJ the same as you jae-joon or so
oh my god so to see I'm like a different
kind of group that he can delegate to or
manage
he's definitely type-a - I will say that
but he yeah he manages engineering and I
don't really touch his engineering
because I don't know what I'm doing
there and then neighbors here are so
amazing and I should not be telling any
of them what to do um so I he and I are
super different I think a lot of people
I'm extremely like blunt and I don't
hold back at all and he's a little bit
more savvy and tactful probably with how
he gives feedback if I'm being honest
there's a few differences that make him
much stronger than I and then some
differences that make me stronger you
know we both have our pros and cons okay
so you in other words like kind of have
developed this whole company around
people that you can manage well that's
just for my management team I know there
are definitely people here who I've
struggled with managing and now they
report to someone else and we're good to
go and they're doing a great job so I
would just say overall the people who
report directly to me I want to make
sure I have a great relationship with
them but there are people at this
company who if they were ported to me
they would be failing and I would be
failing working with them but that's
okay because they work great with
someone else and with what else has been
difficult for you aside from managing
other things uh focusing on focusing I
know that's in silly but um you really
want to be good at one or two core
things and there are so many shiny
objects out there and especially in our
space our space is super broken like HR
Tech is pretty behind the times I mean
we're sending men and women to space and
yet we're still like really struggling
to get applicant tracking system
integrations and place like really basic
technology issues and so what I would
say is there are so many opportunities
and so many things we want to do and
deciding and prioritizing what you want
to do is really hard the good news is I
just hired this awesome VP product who
should really be happy with that
so hopefully that works out not gonna
would ya okay because there are what
it's what's a UPS unique insight because
there are obviously of competitors right
like what do you guys do differently
so we have three components to our
platform for candidates one is a job
board one is candidate sourcing so
profiles and one is content and advice
so the job board is not just you know
you go to indeed.com and if you and I
both go let's say I'm an amazing
engineer and you and I both look up
engineering jobs on indeed we're gonna
get the exact same recommendations cuz
you're probably logged out etc and I'm
probably logged out they don't know
anything about us I think that's crazy
like you should not have to scroll
through thousands of links we should be
giving you personalized recommendations
based on who you are what you want what
other people who look like you want it
look like you from like a standpoint of
what school or what your is and the list
goes on I'm so personalized
recommendations candidate sourcing is
somewhat similar to LinkedIn but as I
mentioned we have these amazing profiles
that really show who you are in your
best light you are more than your work
history we want to show that and
recruiters can log in and search through
people just like you know a LinkedIn for
example and they can message you if
they're interested in speaking to you
about a potential job opportunity so
that really drives a lot of hires and
then the third aspect is brand is
content advice have you prepared for
this interview or hey we saw that you
were looking at this job at you know
Unilever and we saw you didn't apply why
here is a piece of here's a piece of
content about why Unilever is such an
awesome place to work for and so we have
lots of its this integrated approach
that we're really just trying to help as
many people figure out what they want to
do and then actually get that job and so
one in three people who apply on my up
get hired which we're really proud about
that really few other if any job sites
have been able to tell cool and this is
a problem that I'm trying to figure out
at YC all the time like what is the most
effective content for the most amount of
people and in our shoes it's like
getting people start companies right so
what it what has been the most effective
piece of content for you guys in terms
of getting people to apply through way
up I think often I don't have a great
answer other than like unique content
that will actually make a company or a
job stand out as being you know not
something you know combat the myths that
they might misunderstand so you look at
an investment being on Wall Street so I
was just talking to
right before this and they are a classic
Wall Street bulge bracket bank and you
look at them and you think they're
probably a bunch of boring white dudes
in a room banking all day 6 a.m. to 2
a.m. I played for some reason doing
something yeah they don't care about the
world like there's all these horrible
myths about it and then you actually
speak to them and you learn about what
they're doing and you actually realize
some people are exactly like that but
there's also really really cool jobs and
really cool opportunities and so how can
we highlight what makes some companies
and some jobs really unique for the
specific reader so we try to do a little
bit less at skill content and a little
bit more targeted content around this
piece of content we hope engineers who
also happen to be diverse you know some
kind of underrepresented minority
whether it's female engineers or diverse
engineers etc will read this piece of
content we hope that freshmen will read
this type of content etc and then what
we can do with our databases we'll send
it out to the right people who we want
to read it and are you doing like
Facebook ads and stuff like that really
targeted towards freshmen engineers we
do some Facebook Ads we don't do too
many but we definitely have one person
who's okay got you
so broadly how do you feel about the
where education is going in terms of
preparing yourself to be employed or
starting a company I love how many
companies are snow longer obsessed with
a college degree and are now starting to
think more about skills I love how many
companies don't give a [ __ ] what your
major is I think that's really important
I mean I went into product marketing and
had never taken a single marketing class
at Penn or in my life I still don't
always know what marketing is I was an
English major I have no idea one time I
asked a bunch of people at my company
what do you do and what did you study
and not one of them had studied a single
thing related to what they do so I think
the long story short is I love that
people are using their educational
experience I love when I hear that
people use their education to learn
about things that they love and not
necessarily that they want to do for a
career
because you might be super passionate
about chemistry love studying it love
studying oceanography but not actually
want to be a scientist or study the
oceans and I think that that's really
cool that the way companies are moving
is allowing you to have that kind of
channel for studying what you're
passionate about and not necessarily
having to go into that career maybe
maybe it's just something you want to
study okay and if you're a small company
say you're like you just did YC and
you're gonna make your first hire how do
you make yourself look attractive to all
these you know fresh like wide-eyed
college grads I think it's two things
number one showing why your company is
really interesting and special and
usually that's part of just the mission
and what you're accomplishing or what
you're trying to accomplish and then
number two making it very clear that the
team is amazing and that you are going
to be part of the beginning of something
really special and huge people don't
join startups because of the
compensation that's for sure like they
joined because of the team and the
mission and I think you have to focus on
that hmm so now you've been running this
company for several years now what do
you imagine your life looks like in ten
years ten years a long time I know it's
like more than a third of okay so I can
talk about what I will hope I have
accomplished by that it's super corny
but I've always said I want to make a
difference in the world and I want to be
remembered for making a change for the
better and so I really hope that I'll
have accomplished that in ten years ten
years is a really long time so I hope
way up will be the thing that helps me
accomplish that and and you know maybe
I'll have done something else by then
who knows um how do you think you'll
you'll have improved yourself like what
are you working on right now to get
better at I hope I'll be a better
everything team member manager thinker
product person market or sales person I
mean I'm improving in literally every
area at all times right now I am
figuring out how to be better at
answering questions or interviews so I I
hope I'll get better at everything and
then personalize like ten years you know
for all the women watching I
I hope I'll have a family by then I'm so
glad if I'm being honest like I have
some friends who are founders of really
early companies and I have babies or
they're pregnant I don't know how they
do it I mean I have a dog and I'm like
constantly like though I should say
forget it I was like I'm freaking out of
that oh my god well I remember to put up
food like a human being is a whole
nother animal literally so I I hope to
have had a child and or more and you
know be married and all that stuff but
professionally I hope to have had some
kind of like really big impact on the
world that I'll be remembered for my
favorite thing career-wise I hope I'll
just love whatever I'm doing my favorite
piece of advice I ever got was actually
and I always say this to college
students my college graduation one of my
friend's dad's turned to me and said you
know people spend their whole lives
being so paranoid about making sure that
they marry the right person and you
spend so much time dating and figuring
out who the perfect match is the
soulmate and they don't do that with
their careers because I guess it's a
little more taboo to be divorced than it
is to switch jobs but you spend more
time with your job in your career than
you do with your spouse for the first 40
years of your marriage most likely
unless you retire really early so like
really making sure that you find the
right job or a job that's gonna make you
happy so that you're not miserable every
day is equally as important as often it
is finding a spouse so if you are so
lucky as to be able to have a choice I
would say you know for me I hope I'll be
able to have a choice and have a job
that I love mm-hmm and so for yeah for a
college student like someone who was in
your shoes or is in your shoes how do
they find the thing that they really
care about I mean obviously doing as
much as you can by way of part-time job
an internship so you can have tested
that out before you go into her for your
first full-time job most commonly when I
see people switching their first
full-time job within less than a year
which a lot of people do is you know um
it's often because they just never had
an opportunity to try it out in college
to like try out everything in college
and by the way there's a really cool
site called way they can find it but I
would say you know not doing something
for the money I I mean I know it's so
attractive to be able to pay back your
student loans but it's also so
attractive to be able to be happy at
your job and you're gonna do such a
better job at your
if you're happy so I think I think doing
something that you think you're gonna
love and working with people who you
think will teach you is infinitely the
best decision for your first job and
your second and your third and every job
I think that's such great advice like
just get started early and don't worry
about it being perfect I had so many
shitty internships that were just like
oh okay don't need yes it was mostly
shitty cuz I didn't get paid anything I
was working in an animation studio and
that was actually fun yeah but how I had
to make ends meet while living in New
York was less fun like working now and
like the government's made it really
hard to legally have an unpaid
internship so there are ways but it's
way less common we have less than 9% of
internships on way up or unpaid so oh
wow I just graduate in 2011 so things
have changed yeah yeah so I would say
the same thing just get started early
and go to school in a city yeah I would
also recommend oh really yeah yeah I
mean I loved going to school in Philly
but I think yeah I think you can make
both work I was jealous of like all my
friends who you know lived on like the
quad and had all of that but like
starting in New York at 18 to me was so
awesome yeah so yeah anyway cool well
thanks for coming in yeah thank you for
having me or actually thanks for hosting
you